tech fans have started queueing outside
apple stores ahead of the rumored launch
of a new smartwatch
apple is expected to confirm an updated
iphone model and give details of a new
product which analysts are already
calling the iwatch let's get our latest
the latest from our technology
correspondent tom cheshire who's at
university college london's institute of
sport exercise and health so tom why
there
well the reason i'm here on this
treadmill is to top up on my step count
for the day what we're expecting from
the apple eye watch that's been done we
don't know exact details but we do know
there's going to be a very strong focus
on healthcare with the tracker a bit
like this this is called a jawbone up
i've been using it to track my uh my
life here so you can see my sleep
patterns i managed six hours 15 minutes
i could probably do better and i've done
8 000 steps a day so these wearables
have been around a long time there are
several different ones you go but when
apple gets hold of something like a
phone or an mp3 player it tends to make
it go a bit more mainstream so i think
that's what we're going to be focusing
on for the main part tonight
but yes there's also some developments
as far as the new iphone is concerned as
well you might be able to spend money
using it is that right
well yeah this is quite an exciting
thing and it might also be related to
health but nfc enabled so the idea is
you'll be able to tap your phone or
maybe tap your watch pay for your oyster
card pay for you know a coffee in
starbucks or whatever apple already has
millions of credit cards hundreds of
millions of credit cards thanks just
itunes says talked with the major credit
card providers uh to turn that into a
payment system which could be a pretty
big deal on top of that you've got the
sort of more standard thing of the new
iphone which is going to come in two
different sizes one slightly bigger than
the existing iphone and then a much
bigger version we don't know exactly
when those will go on sale there's
rumored of an ultra
high resistant display but we'll hear
all at 6 00 p.m tonight
and uh who's gonna buy
the iwatch if it is indeed uh called
that and it is indeed announced is it
going to be young hipsters like yourself
or is it going to go more mainstream do
you think
i think i'm slightly mainstream in my
taste um i mean i've been trying this
out and it is fun you get to see how
much you've slept how much you've eaten
um what exercise you could be doing but
we all know we should be exercising more
sleeping more
going to bed earlier and that sort of
stuff if apple wants to crack this they
are really good at taking geeky products
like if you remember mp3 players before
the ipod
tablets before the ipad those were
really nice products and then they made
the mainstream they come out with a
watch that costs around 300 pounds
there's a big market there and they'll
be hoping to do it they're so good at
design um they might have an interesting
spin that we haven't thought of that
isn't just an improved version this it
sort of rethinks it differently
well tom you're making me tired there so
i'm gonna say goodbye but uh thank you
for that and you definitely need to get
a bit more sleep
okay
tom thank you